hey guys Ryan right here and tonight I'm
gonna be watching the trailer for the
purge anarchy the second trailer for it
I've seen the first one already first
one was like okay then the acting
doesn't look so great but the concepts
pretty cool how it's not just like a
home invasion movie like it's going
around the world like here's what kind
of goes on outside of that [ __ ] house
so I'm excited to see that concept be
explored it's just the [ __ ] couple
from the trailer just in an intrigued me
but it's the purge man I love the idea
way more than I actually like the first
movie this idea is grand like they can
totally make something spectacular out
of this terrifying idea now I'm hoping
this trailer is gonna make me feel like
it could possibly do that purged and
approved nope you know how dangerous it
is that's right yeah pack some heat in
back it won't make you feel any better
acting is shitty already it's late
traffic is building rapidly downtown
citizens rush to get home before
commencement
if you're not purging we advise you to
get off the streets as quickly as
possible it'll soon be a war system
announcing the commencement of the
annual purge it's a party love to just
see that on the road one day
you can't be a hero on the purge
people spend a lot of money to purge oh
it scary
as long as we keep movin
don't survive tonight
this is the last purge of the evening
the bidding started 200,000 but a
[ __ ] spoiler just giving away way too
much
who knows maybe it's not the ending yeah
perch does a lot of good it seems I want
to see a purge movie where you're like
totally all for letting people die
you're on The Killers side the whole
time that would be one hell of an
adventure the concept I think is better
I love the idea of how you're actually
gonna be able to explore the territories
now you're gonna be able to explore the
areas it seems much better that way but
the acting doesn't seem to be that great
I thought the trailer gave away a little
too much who knows maybe that [ __ ]
doesn't happen at the end I don't know
but it looks like there will be some
really sick kills and when you hear
movie like the purge you want to see
some sick kills but I would love to see
a movie of the purge because the purge
could also be kind of a comedy I mean
you could like [ __ ] do whatever you
want go piss in the kids playground at
the [ __ ] McDonald's go [ __ ] on Paris
Hilton's face I don't know why all my
purging has to do with going to the
bathroom maybe because purging sounds
like a bathroom activity but yeah you
guys would you did the channel subscribe
this particular moment I'd love to give
a shout out to a man named Marcus
workman and every time there's a video
out he'd make sure to subscribe and make
sure it is he doesn't rhesus kryb every
time he makes her to comment he's an
awesome dude thank you for supporting
the channel my friend you know I just
I've really talked to you guys a lot and
I want to show you guys that sometimes
yeah actually it's like all the time I'm
very obedient to whenever you guys
request stuff I have a list of like 55
things I gotta watch actually it's like
70 so I Plex not recording and get to it